[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans votre magazine de
l'éducation ils sont 12 millions 12
millions d'élèves à franchir les portes
des écoles des collèges et des lycées
tous les matins alors pour mieux
comprendre les méthodes des enseignants
et regarder d'un peu plus près les
journées de vos enfants nous partons à
la rencontre de tous ceux qui font
l'école vous allez tout savoir grâce à
liberté égalité scolarité
et dans cette émission on va parler des
élèves allophones ces enfants qui ne
connaissent pas un mot de français et
qui ont soif d'apprendre dans nos écoles
viser les médailles et les bonnes notes
voilà l'objectif des élèves de l'île cep
nous avons suivi une journée dans
l'agenda très rempli de deux futurs
champions en parlant de championne en
voilà une qui joue cette année son 18e
tournoi de roland garros alizé cornet
nous racontera ses souvenirs d'école
sans oublier notre clin d'oeil aux
archives cette fois nous reviendrons sur
l'évolution de la formation
professionnelle
[Musique]
qu'il soit ukrainien philippin ou
ivoiriens quand un enfant débarque sur
le sol français même sans parler un mot
de notre langue il est accueilli à
l'école de la république
il intègre alors un dispositif pour
élèves allophones comme au fond les
professeurs spécialisés pour inclure au
mieux ses élèves au parcours souvent
traumatisant la réponse ici au collège
jean baptiste lebas à roubaix
[Musique]
joe allen bonjour valérie merci beaucoup
de nous accueillir dans le collège jean
baptiste lebas alors vous êtes une prof
un petit peu particulière expliquez nous
en fait j'ai une classe de 4e comme
professeur de lettres coordination
parcours ordinaire et je suis également
professeur du peu de ça c'est à dire je
m'occupe des élèves allophones qui
viennent d'arriver en france
[Musique]
bonjour c'est bon ça va
ça va bien attentat tout autant ça va
bien
merci ça va bien comment ça va bien et
toi ami de ça va bien oui ok super aller
en place tu es un dessin tu as un petit
texte il faut relier le bond des chemins
avec le bon texte tu comprends oui
magnifique ligne suivante
on te demande quoi je fus
garçons alors tu vois le petit signe là
en dessous du seuil ça fait le son
garçon et après vous allez dire de
quelle couleur sans vos yeux silviu
marron
marron aussi
et moi vous soyez dire quelle couleur
ils sont mes yeux ce bleu ces bleus en
effet comment on fait pour se faire
comprendre d'un enfant qui n'a jamais
entendu parler le français d'abord on
utilise des rituels le rituel du bonjour
que vous avez vu tout à l'heure c'est un
rituel qui permet d'acquérir les bases
de la communication
bonjour comment ça va ça va bien merci
voilà on dessine beaucoup en groupe
grands débutants parce que l'association
du dessin et des mots forcément ça fait
sens un enfant qui rentre dans le
dispositif en général reste combien de
temps un an deux ans trois ans notre
objectif c'est de l'enfer partir le plus
rapidement possible donc un élève qui au
bout de six mois serait prêt à suivre
des cours de classe ordinaire sans
besoin de soutien en français
particulier peut très bien quitter le
dispositif encore d'année juste derrière
vous il ya un élève qui est arrivé il ya
dix jours c'est cela cesse l'arctique
une alternance et sabour qui regardent
avec mons et ans bonjour
bonjour monsieur il est arrivé avec sa
famille
il ya quelques temps suite justement la
situation en afghanistan et ne parlait
pas un mot de français parce que vous
avancez qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu
peux nous dire
très bien tu as quel âge faut quand on
veut d'accord ton pays
moi je suis française et toi tu es
afghan afghans voilà vous laisse
continuer merci au revoir
[Musique]
bonjour je vous accueillez les élèves
allophones comment vous voyez qualifiée
un peu leur sentiment quand il arrive
pour la première fois ici ils ont
forcément des craintes parce qu'ils
connaissent pas parce qu'ils connaissent
pas le fonctionnement d'une école
française mais très vite c'est des
élèves qui s'intègre très facilement
dans l'école est très régulièrement nos
élèves primo arrivants sont félicités en
fin d'année parce qu'ils deviennent
rapidement des élèves très très bon
scolairement parce qu'ils savent que
l'école est un des vecteurs les plus
importants de réussite ici en france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là qu'est ce qu'on retrouve comme
à et la vo on retrouve les élèves du
groupe à deux c'est à dire le groupe
intermédiaire est ce qu'on fait le texte
d'harpagon de la main oui tout 500 aller
1 2 3
ou même plus judicieux gilles a dû
s'incliner on va quand oublier la gorge
on m'a donné ma chance je suis mort
je suis en terminale et
l'intonation il était donc je le veux
comme ça il est désespéré
[Musique]
oui le lieu c'est là on va tu t'appelles
i dream je sais qu'un redoux les séries
tu viens d'où il vient ce virus d'accord
ok et comment tu es arrivé en france
en bateau et donc tu es tu es là à
roubaix depuis combien de temps est
presque presque presque deux ans
a appris plein de choses qu'est ce que
ça a pris comme chose comment je vais
dire 10 comme tu veux comme tu le sens
bien ce truc de ouf quand j'ai dépassé
je ne le connaissais pas comment
conjuguer au passé oui le congre contre
que veut dire je peux recommencer
athlètes
un autre verbe où ils sont entre auch
pas ou un autre temps peut-être russe en
outre ton métier quand je dis
heureusement le futur plein de fric ah
oui mais c'est compliqué c'est qu'on
fait que c'est normal
[Musique]
on va dans une faille dans laquelle se
trouve le parent qui suivent le perdre
c'est à ce qu est un dispositif qui
n'est pas obligatoire consiste à
proposer des cours de français au tarot
migrants
charline sortie sans fond chaque
dimanche dans la chambre de jeune pour
ça que c'est mentir la championne
essayé à l'exercice vous les payez aller
charlie champigny chanson chaque
dimanche dans la chambre du château
[Applaudissements]
donc vous avez des enfants qui sont dans
le collège un enfant de neuf ans deux
enfants ils seront réussies zombies coup
mais moi ils m'ont paru vraiment c'est
comme si le maintenant à mon avis que
des cours j'ai fait j'ai participé au c
est
conseillé par an des belles phrases
c'est bien ouais super participe hisser
% moment ok mais bon c'est fort parlait
bien français
cette fin de vacances
[Musique]
quelques échauffements pour vous parler
des cent mille collégiens et lycéens qui
en france ont choisi la section sportive
scolaire ce que l'on appelait avant le
sport études ici nous sommes à l'insep à
vincennes tout près de paris c'est
l'établissement qui forment les graines
de champions les élèves y font du sport
beaucoup de sport mais attention pas
question de négliger l'histoire
géographie ou les maths ici l'exigence
est à tous les niveaux avec des journées
bien remplies regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour est ce qu'elle comprend un judo
large s'il vous plaît
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
salut les filles fanny est ce que je
peux m'asseoir votre table il bien sûr
comment ça va ambre sama qu'est-ce qu'on
prend au petit déj quand on est une
athlète à chocolat chaud ouais un verre
de jus de pomme d'accord et un bout de
pain et de la confiture c'est quoi la
suite du programme ces balles en cours
pour deux heures ensuite je vais à la
gym gd manger ici hôtel vous pouvez en
cours l'après-midi pour une heure et je
vais à nouveau la gym pour trois heures
de gym ensuite je vais manger et je fais
l'étude du soir au caire l'étude du soir
c'est les devoirs césar ok on te
retrouve tout à l'heure en cours alors
oui bon ah bah tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est bien
ça va ouais tous les matins tu viens
vers 7h30 heure et demie ouais après on
voit en cours du ces 9 55 9h40 après
généralement seul dans ma chambre où
seul juge ait au moins une menace pour
shooter basket ont entraînement 11h 12h
15 et après la musculation du bas rhin
c'est à 13h après jour la grande chine
la cour de 14h30 à 16h15 reprendre
l'entraînement dès 16h30 avant la
probable - j'ai tenté classe troisième
ok
je mesure combien dont 99 c'est pas
dégoûté pas faire de maître nombre
bientôt bientôt tu penses que tu va
grandir encore bah ça j'écoute 15 ans
non tu vas faire que de mettre 30 non
mais c'est pas les 2 m 2 bon allez je te
laisse est en cours
mais
qui est le père en fait de l'anti
bonelli semaine j'y vois la rue d'ypres
après s'est marié avec eux la reine sauf
que ce que l'on prédit qu'il avait marié
avec sa mère du coup ils savaient pas
que c'était sa main je peux soumaré je
lui quatre enfants
qui règne ici vient du latin tyrannicide
yom signifie tian et décide yom qui
n'est bon alors vous oubliez pas surtout
pour les questions pour le brevet si on
vous de voir comment est composée se
moquer ce qu'il faut répondre alors j'ai
pas toujours de prix fixe et pas
toujours suffi que ça on garde toujours
un radical il faut bien répondre en
donnant le maximum dès
l'es2
[Musique]
le coup est terminée oui et comment vous
faites pour faire rentrer le programme
de troisième avec toutes ces heures de
sport alors ce qui veut dire c'est que
ja la classe g que lui fait frais
réunissant 4 donc ça aide donc on peut
beaucoup plus individualisé travail et
travailler plus vite et aussi travailler
plus vite on l'a vraiment en moins
d'heures après on évaluer au mieux en
fonction de ce que finalement les
fédérations nous accorde
et puis ça dépend aussi des disciplines
tant d'autres gymnastes chaque envie de
faire que une heure de pur alors qu'il y
en a deux programmes y est long celui de
rattraper cette heure et lorsque c'est
encore plus difficile pour elle
[Musique]
allez allez allez les gars t'as fait
qu'à sa tête bien dans la tête je ne
sais pas la tête qui colle fixed en tête
des ventes avec les bras
[Musique]
c'est bien ça va les entraîneurs doit
avoir son tir d'offres comprendre et
doivent savoir quels sont les moyens les
gymnastes et jusqu'à où on peut le
pousser parce que si on les pousse au
delà de leurs moyens justement ventre
cela nous en avons qui s'appelle le
danger et on évite toute forme de
blessures pour que la continuité de
chaque gymnaste de biens importante
attention j'essaye
même pas sur tout
alors je voulais savoir est-ce que ça
t'arrive de te dire
mais pourquoi je vais à l'école alors
que moi ma passion c'est la gymnastique
est en fait peut-être que je gagnerai à
m'entraîner encore plus à faire encore
plus d'heures de l'entraînement comme on
a vu tout à l'heure est ce que ça
t'arrive de dire ça bah non pas trop
parce que j'ai c'est que la gym je
pourrais pas en faire mon métier parce
que ça s'arrête assez tôt donc faut
quand même que je suive les cours même
temps que plus tard je pourrais pas
faire de gym encore à 40 ans on va donc
faut quand même que je travaille
l'objectif c'est quoi voilà celesio à
long terme des shows les prochains il
assume 2024 à paris ça va être un peu
jce les prochains c'est 2024 s'ils n'ont
cessé de 1028 hockey lac saint jean est
ok donc une médaille quoi une médaille
d'or
et une houle si jamais tu as une
médaille d'or tu nous la ramènera la
chaîne parlementaire
cool bon elles vont être laissés
continue est un rude journée alors oui
bon si merci à toi merci beaucoup
m
[Applaudissements]
quand même
je ne peux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
l'objectif est de devenir un grand
champion comme
qu'on a voulu ce qu'on a voilà ce qu'on
a voulu ce qu'on a voulu montrer à nos
jeunes qui arrivent sont arrivés c'est
cette année c'est de montrer ben voilà
les médaillés à tokyo qui ont étudié
l'unsa qui ont étudié les sept qui sont
passés par saint thomas la sicile
étaient assises sur les mêmes chaise
même table teddy riner bien sûr j'ai eu
la chance d'être son bon professeur de
mathématiques en troisième s'est pas
vraiment laissé un très bon souvenir il
était mon maître il n'était pas trop
louis était pas trop mal
même si des fois il ya eu des moments où
il a fallu forcément barre les soutenir
un peu plus puis retardé certaines
choses est ce qu'il y a des cancres à
l'insep
n'y a pas de temps à l'insep on a des
jeunes qui sont voilà
très investi dans le projet de
performance et et des fois il faut un
petit peu bien les accompagner sur leur
projet scolaire cette année c'est peut
être un peu difficile pour eux mais
globalement on peut dire que ce sont des
jeunes qui sont investis dans leurs deux
projets dans leur double projet
marc
tahar est ici pour tirer là après du
poids
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention tu prêt
c'est quoi l'objectif en venant à
l'insset pour moi de besoin de bien
travailler d'avoir mon brevet à la fin
de l'année ça c'est sûr tu as well
normalement et sportivement bah c'est de
progresser de passer dès l'es4 pour que
l'été est bien des équipes de france bat
y viennent et pour qu'on jouait les
coupes des coupes d'europe où les coups
de genou à la fin le top du top c'est là
une belle équipe de france ce temps le
ballon qu'en train de persil salez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
champion de france à 14 ans championne
d'europe à 15 alizé cornet travail
servair et ses coups droits depuis l'âge
de 4 ans mais comment s'organiser ces
journées entre cours d'école et terre
battue j'ai mis mes plus belles baskets
pour justement lui poser la question sur
un court de tennis ici à roland garros
bonjour bonjour alizé cornet bienvenue
dans mon jardin oui c'est ça merci de
vous accueillir sur internet vous
connaissez bien finalement pour des
plaisirs bon améliorer s'installer j'ai
quelques questions à vous poser sa vache
comment vous organisiez un peu le sport
à côté d'eux à côté de l'école alors en
primaire c'était très facile parce qu'en
fait jusqu'à assez tard j'ai joué au
tennis seulement une fois par semaine et
je faisais juste les cours du mercredi
comme tout enfant lambda c'était
vraiment une scolarité on peut plus
banal c'est vraiment à partir du collège
que là ça j'ai dû commencer à faire des
choix j'ai commencé à gagner des
compétitions internationales
là ça a été compliqué parce que j'ai dû
partir au cned est là le rythme s'est
légèrement accéléré puisque en fait je
devais travailler tout seul de chez moi
j'avais 80 pour l'expliquer c'est les
cours par correspondance
j'avais quatre à six heures
d'entraînement par jour plus bas du coup
les cours en fin de journée où ma mère
veiller au grain pour que j'envoye les
devoirs dans les temps et tout ça mais
c'était quand même vraiment pas évident
et j'avais quelques profs qui venaient à
la maison pour me pompe d'un coup main
donc c'était vraiment le rythme de
l'armée quoi y avait pas une minute qui
était pas programmés dans la journée et
j'en ai des souvenirs des bons souvenirs
mais assez assez difficile quand même de
suivre le rythme et c'est vrai que quand
j'ai eu la chance de passer mon bac je
les passais à 16 ans parce que j'avais
j'avais deux ans d'avancé j'ai eu un
sentiment de liberté tout d'un coup
d'avoir la sensation que ça et je
pouvais vraiment me lancer dans le
tennis à corps perdu donc c'était
c'était agréable alors pour revenir
avant le bac en primaire de cette
période vous nous avez ramené quelques
quelques objets mme daffé l'échec donc
voilà alors la fameuse photo de classe
alors nous c'est la classe on on pose
est quand même sur le port de nice on
peut voir les mâts des bateaux derrière
donc voilà bon j'imagine quand vous avez
déjà trouvé à l'énergie chère je cherche
assez facilement west est là tout à fait
mais reconnaît vous n'avez pas bougé je
sais pas pourquoi j'avais choisi cette
pause
donc voilà la trousse alors j'ai
toujours été une grande fan du petit
prince ça a été le premier livre que
j'ai lu je pense en entier et ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'à l'intérieur je laisse
ce sens les premières lunettes offre ça
tellement mignon fait
en plus elles ont exactement la même
forme que c'est ce que je fais
aujourd'hui et donc voilà donc là dedans
j'avais bon p'tit bazar les compas les
crayons et stylos la petite élève qui
justement avait ses crayons ses
ustensiles de maths dans cette trousse
elle pensé à quoi à être la meilleure
c'était son obsession à cette petite
fille c'était avoir des vingt sur vingt
en permanence ne pas décevoir ses
parents être la meilleure de la classe
alors j'étais une fayote tout alors moi
mais j'assume ces jeux lever le doigt
mais alors jusqu au collage en plus ça
n'avait pas j'avais pas de complexe je
le fais le doigt en classe gt toujours
celle qui répondait aux questions au
delà d'être faillite c'était peut-être
aussi une question de confiance en vous
que vous aviez peut-être ou peut-être le
manque de confiance en moi en fait je me
demande pas ce que j'avais toujours
envie de trouver quelque chose prouver
que que j'écoutais que j'étais là que je
suivais des cours aujourd'hui vous
publiez un livre la valse des jours
est-ce que enfants adolescentes parce
que vous écriviez déjà dans des carnets
d'andean décaillet ouais ouais ouais mon
premier rêve en tant que petit fils
n'étaient pas des jeux et à nice était
d'être écrivain voilà est donc là à 32
ans d'avoir mon premier roman qu'est
publié j'ai l'impression un peu de
renouer avec cette petite fille like qui
finalement a mis beaucoup de choses de
côté pour le tennis qui a sacrifié
énormément de choses pour ce sport et
qui en revient peut-être à sa toute
première aussi
[Musique]
merci je vais faire toucher c'est trop
choix de la patrie
[Musique]
après la 3e chaque élève peut décidé
d'apprendre un métier en choisissant
directement la voie professionnelle
ces apps et bep bac pro les chemins qui
mènent à la vie active sont variés et
ils ont beaucoup évolué avec le temps
c'est notre capsule old school préparé
par le réseau canopée
ces apps et bep bac pro voilà le graal
pour les élèves apprenant un métier dans
des établissements qu'on a tour à tour
appelé ses hôtes et lep puis lycée pro
petit décryptage de la voie
professionnelle
depuis sa création au 19e siècle
l'enseignement professionnel a beaucoup
évolué d'abord pensé et organisé par les
patrons et pour les patrons il répond
aux besoins en main d'oeuvre qualifiée
c'est l'orientation naturel de tous ceux
qui veulent rentrer rapidement dans la
vie active en travaillant à l'usiné ou
en reprenant l'atelier familial
l'apprentissage
après-guerre l'état reprend la main sur
les entreprises en scolarisant les
formations et en contrôlant la
délivrance des diplômes car
l'enseignement professionnel doit former
l'homme le travailleur et le citoyen les
heures d'enseignement général augmente
face aux apprentissages techniques et à
la pratique monsieur t c'est tout varié
l'enseignement général et l'enseignement
ménager puis l'atelier mais
l'allongement progressif de
l'instruction obligatoire va avoir une
conséquence inédite face au manque de
places dans la voie générale on commence
à reléguer dans les filières
professionnelles des élèves en échec
scolaire c'est le début d'une
dévalorisation qui perdure encore
aujourd'hui la fin de la troisième
j'espère aller en seconde on m'a proposé
le bep parce qu'on nage était pas apte à
l'est ainsi que londres
n'était pas assez forte en mathématiques
je suis une première année de bep compta
j'ai été assez déçu j'ai rien fait
jusqu'aux années 60 les filles sont
poussés vers les collèges et lycées
d'enseignement technique quand les
garçons atterrissent plutôt un
apprentissage mais après mai 68
travaillait comme menuisier ou
secrétaires toute sa vie ne fait plus
rêver grand monde 8h sur l'écran c'est
pas varié du tout ce qu'on fait c'est
que des leds que des lettres mais
j'aimerais faire autre chose la montée
du chômage qui accompagnent les années
soixante dix sonne comme un verdict les
formations sont visiblement inadaptées
la loi haby de 1975 réorganise les
établissements avec l'idée de maintenir
la majorité des élèves dans la voie
générale avant de les orienter en fin de
collège puis en 1985 le bac pro doit
permettre d'amener 80 % d'une classe
d'âge au bac en dix ans le nombre de
bacheliers passe de trois cent mille à
500 milles dont 40% titulaire d'un bac
pro
ces trente dernières années
l'enseignement professionnel s'est
emparé de dispositifs d'accompagnement
et de pédagogie innovante visant à
favoriser la poursuite d'études ou
l'entrée sur le marché du travail
aujourd'hui la voie professionnelle
forme à une multitude de métiers dans la
construction durable la gestion
administrative
l'alimentation l'aéronautique le
numérique et les transitions
énergétiques
l'éventail est large
et si la voie professionnelle reste
fidèle à sa promesse de former l'homme
le travailleur et le citoyen elle sera
capable d'accompagner les jeunes vers ce
monde de demain à inventer
[Musique]
et voilà c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouve très vite pour un
prochain numéro de liberté égalité
scolarité
[Musique]